it's fair to say that everyone in our
house absolutely adores picnics
and not just the kids
tana and i love them as well
so get ready for six perfect portable
dishes here's my ultimate picnic food
first sausage and egg roll into one in
my twist on a favorite picnic breakfast
scotch eggs
look great don't they lean grenades
a wonderful picnic lunch of spiced
carrot cumin and orange salad can't
really ask much more from a carrot can
you
and a giant mediterranean sandwich to
feed an entire family who would not want
to join you on a picnic with a sandwich
like that and where there's chocolate
and marshmallows tilly is never far away
marshmallow my favorite
for our picnic tea she's getting stuck
in with a sticky chocolate marshmallow
and peanut fridge cake
it's so good
a splendid seaside anchovy dip with
crudites and a prawn and cucumber salad
with a spicy yogurt dressing
come on it's a bit like a tummy
see
three amazing moveable feasts to keep
your family and friends energized for
alfresco fun through breakfast lunch and
dinner
first up the perfect picnic breakfast my
ultimate scotch eggs with a twist
[Music]
i go fishing a lot and scotch eggs are
the perfect all-in-one mini picnic
breakfast first thing get your eggs
cooked bring the water up the boil onto
the spoon
and lower them into the water that way
they don't hit the water and crack four
and a half minutes that will keep the
center
nice and slightly runny
now
ground sausage meat i'm gonna make mine
a little bit spicier i'm gonna crumble
in black pudding that helps to season
the scotch eggs inside a little touch of
salt and pepper
and then just to make it a little bit
sweeter and a lot easier for the kids to
eat some grated apple
[Music]
combine that
blend in the apple and the black pudding
eggs once they're cooked drain them and
then run them under cold water
cracking and cooling the eggs quickly
will prevent the yolks turning gray
tap them on the side of the pan
put them back into the water and what
happens the water seeps underneath the
shell
see the shell come off so much easier
eggs still slightly soft in the center i
want that little bit of richness with
the yolk
next you need to get yourself organized
with a mini assembly line
seasoned flour
a little egg wash
and breadcrumbs
take
your mince golf ball size
spread the pate manipulate with your
thumb
and then
sit your egg in there
and spread
the sausage over the egg
and you just seal that over
it's really important to keep that nice
even coating of sausage meat around the
egg you don't want it too thick
otherwise it gets too dense and it's
unappetizing
give them a light dusting in the
seasoned flour
if you don't put the flour on the egg
wash won't stick if you don't put the
egg wash on the breadcrumbs won't stick
into the egg
roll it round
shake off any excess egg wash and roll
it into your breadcrumbs you can use
this same three stage method to
breadcrumb anything you like from
chicken guzons and fish fillets to fina
schnitzel
these are panko breadcrumbs japanese
white breadcrumb so no crust
you can experiment by adding flavors to
your breadcrumbs like parmesan herbs or
citrus zest
i always like to push the actual
breadcrumbs into the sausage meat so it
gets that really nice golden brown and
stops any of the outside burning
once breadcrumbed lower the eggs
carefully into a four centimetre deep
bath of hot vegetable oil for 10 to 12
minutes
the eggs are actually cooked
soft and running the center so the
objective is just to cook the sausage
meat and the black pudding
they look great don't they going
grenades
there's something so magical about a
scotch egg on a picnic because it's like
this little mini breakfast
beautiful
drain them onto the paper roll them
around
just to get off any excess oil and then
to transport them
some greaseproof paper
that for me is the perfect start to the
fishing trip there's no wonder i never
catch any fish
because i'm always too busy eating my
scotch eggs
[Music]
my ultimate black pudding lace scotch
eggs an irresistibly delicious picnic
breakfast
[Music]
coming up more on my ultimate picnic
dishes but first here's a close look at
some of the key ingredients you'll need
to make them
for my picnic tea i'll be using prawns
from a beautiful translucent blue to
silver gray when raw
turning to pink when cooked the sweet
firm meaty flesh of prawns is hugely
popular across the globe
smaller prawns are likely to be fished
from cold waters of the arctic they are
mostly sold cooked and are best served
cold
large types such as tiger and king
prawns tend to be farmed in warmer
waters and can be bought raw or cooked
[Music]
parma ham is only produced in the palmer
region of northern italy
made from the hind leg of the pig its
unique nutty flavour is said to be
achieved by adding parmesan whey to the
pig's slops
modern curing takes at least a year and
still follows age-old traditions the
perfect cure is achieved with nothing
but sea salt and the tender loving care
of the master salter
i'll be using this delicious sweet soft
ham in my giant picnic lunch sandwich
[Music]
in terms of flavor per gram anchovies
pack a mighty punch
fresh the small saltwater oily fish are
incredible cooked hole
cured and tinned these versatile little
wonders are a must-have store cupboard
ingredient
save the best quality ones for cold
dishes like nisswa salad or an amazing
anchovy butter
i'll be using the small fry with
attitude and a simple but punchy picnic
dip
the key to great picnic recipes is they
have to be practical as well as
delicious
my next two dishes are brilliant
travellers and guaranteed to arrive at
the picnic looking and tasting just as
good as when they were packed
for my perfect picnic lunch a grated
carrot cumin and orange salad
and a spectacular sandwich based on a
classic from southern france
this is a picnic sandwich with a twist
but the secret is in the layers
i'm gonna make a delicious tapenade a
puree of olives seasoned with capers and
anchovies
a nice tablespoon of extra virgin olive
oil
garlic in
a little teaspoon of red wine vinegar
that just sort of zaps up the flavor
quite like leaving it nice and chunky
tastes better and feels richer
i much prefer spreading a smooth layer
of tapenade rather than using butter
now to prepare my first mediterranean
sandwich filling
i want nice long
slices
of yet because yes can be a bland
vegetable
season them nicely
once that grill's nice and hot a
tablespoon of olive oil
the more color you put on those
courgettes the more flavor
while my griddle courgette's cool i can
prepare the bread this is a stunning
beautiful country loaf but we're not
going to slice it i'm just going to cut
the top off because i'm assembling a
picnic sandwich basket
and then an inch from the crust and go
around
scoop out a nice large hollow
don't waste this bread put that out to
dry it makes the most amazing bread
crumbs
the secret now is filling that cavity
with all those wonderful mediterranean
flavors i'm going to leave them to sort
of sit and marinate lightly season the
inside of the loaf
drizzle
of olive oil line with that wonderful
tapenade and spread it generously
puts the groundwork in
starts to set the tone for the flavors
that we're incorporating
traditionally the main protein in
pampanya would be tuna i'm sticking with
the med but replacing the fish with some
of my family's italian favorites
palmer ham i'll start lining my sandwich
from the center
every time i add another ingredient it's
just another stunning layer of texture
and flavor but what i'm thinking about
is what actually complements
the next layer mozzarella
a little spoon of my tapenade
we've got the most amazing tequila
pepper so it's got a nice smoky barbecue
flavor open them up and lay them
on top next layer these wonderful
grilled
courgettes
on top of that
some blush tomatoes
concentrated but really chewy and
delicious and each time lightly press
them down
creamy mozzarella again
and then finally peppers
push that down not too firm
fold in
and seal that with your tapenade
almost like a little glue
now lid on
to seal
all that flavor in there
and not only travels well but actually
tastes delicious
that is one stunning
picnic sandwich
next a brilliant picnic salad that's
just as robust as your pan vanilla
carrots and cumin and orange
perfect combination again travels
brilliantly
it doesn't wilt
it doesn't disintegrate
orange zest
[Music]
squeeze
the orange over
sunflower seeds a bit of crunch in there
pumpkin seeds again
another bite
next a hint of spice toasted cumin seeds
ground with the help of a little coarse
sea salt
a nice fine powder
now for the dressing tablespoon of dijon
mustard tablespoon of honey
half a tablespoon of white wine vinegar
and then a nice glug
of olive oil
fresh mint
and coriander
the minute you start picking fresh herbs
all that flavor comes out a nice mix
delicious vinegar
mix that in
give enough dressing
bind it together excite the palette not
drown it
if it was a leaf salad then i'd take the
dressing separately but because this is
a robust
root vegetable that can sustain being
dressed now
and eaten in two hours time
sweet spicy
fragrant
can't really ask much more from a carrot
can you
beautiful
[Music]
just when your guests think that you're
cutting up a delicious
country loaf
[Music]
look at that baby wow
and who would not want to join you
on a picnic with a sandwich like that
my ultimate picnic lunch to surprise and
impress pan banya bursting with rich
sunshine flavors and serve with a
refreshingly zingy carrot cumin and
orange salad
my ultimate picnic keeps it simple with
dishes that all work brilliantly well
together and that's one of the secrets
you have to treat a picnic like a
celebration meal make sure you've got a
stunning selection and a great balance
of tastes and textures but above all
make sure it's fun
i've saved my three most indulgent
dishes for a tea time picnic treat
a stunning prawn and cucumber salad with
a spicy yogurt dressing
a simply delicious anchovy dip
and a sticky chocolate fridge cake that
won't fail to revive a flag in family
until he's keen to get in on the action
what are your favorites a marshmallow
and peanut fridge cake
perfect for
a picnic first things first you have to
slowly melt the chocolate
[Music]
that's good
i'm gonna break up the chocolate
right in there next butter goes in
couple tablespoons of golden syrup
it's so good if we melt chocolate too
quickly it starts to separate and
destroy
the best and safest way to melt
chocolate is always use a bain-marie but
i'm going to keep a really close eye on
mine and heat it over a super low heat
this stunning little cake has your
favorites in there our digestives now
put your hands in there and give them
like that one at a time ago
and crush what's the one thing that you
love about a picnic
i love eating outside especially on a
nice summery day
not so much in the winter no
that's gonna be the crunchy part of our
fridge cake
and it's called a fridge cake because it
can sit in the fridge or you can freeze
it now the peanuts in please
can you use it without peanuts if you're
allergic to peanuts oh you can do yeah
definitely no
what are these little babies cranberries
cranberries
from there
marshmallows my favorite
okay
they're so bright aren't they why do you
love marshmallows so much because
they're so squishy all right give that a
nice mix up
chocolate is melting nicely okay i want
you to pour that in and i'll mix it nice
and gently slowly slowly slowly
nice
now
touch more please
good isn't it good give that a little
mix with daddy
please look they're all melty and nice
and cool and gooey
now we're gonna line the tray
so this is quite easy to make because um
you don't have to bake it
you just set it yeah i want you to start
pushing it into the corners please with
your fingers just laying out nice and
flat
ah it's all nice and marshmallow and
oozy
to get the spatula okay and look how
delicious does that look
really delicious i can eat it right now
i couldn't because it's not set
all right so when that sets okay
it'll go nice and firm and then we can
cut it into little bars little
squares
triangles triangles
push push good
but the important part of pushing it
down is that we can slice it
and the more we push the thinner we can
slice okay
there we go
[Music]
fridge cake done
now i'm gonna make the most amazing
anchovy dip with vegetables and bread
first cut slices of baguette and bake in
the oven at 180 degrees c for six
minutes or until crisp
meanwhile roughly chop garlic and
shallots and add to a food processor
along with a tin of good quality
anchovies
[Music]
sprinkle in some pitted black olives
flat leaf parsley and drizzle in the
reserved anchovy oil and a little olive
oil
blitz to a paste and add pepper
then decant into a jar ready to
transport
serve with a handful of fresh baby
carrots
peppery radishes and your crisp baguette
toast
anchovy dip a portable and deliciously
palatable alfresco treat
[Music]
now a spicy chili yogurt dressing with a
prawn salad first things first i'd like
you to make the dressing
fish sauce
doesn't really smell like fishes so one
and a half tablespoons of fish sauce
two chilli
i like this especially if you have it on
the side of the pork
little teaspoon of sugar
oh that's it good
in
so four tablespoons of yogurt
three
four
some zest in there
why are you making it in a jam jar not a
bowl well this is for a little picnic
and it's a great way of transporting
we squeeze the lime in there and then we
put the lid on shake it
and then i want you to shut
[Music]
it's a bit like a tummy
see
that sounds like my tummy
only sometimes uh only sometimes thank
you for that
kind of gives you
and the first time you have it's like a
little thingy it's fresh
salty citrusy
but delicious now cucumber and the salad
i want to get rid of all the seeds so if
you just nice and gently
peel
the cucumber why do you feel it can you
not eat the skin on it you can eat the
skin but i want this salad to taste
light and fresh you can use a knife for
this too though can't you you can peel
with a knife but a speed peeler takes
off the slices nice and thinly so much
quicker so much quicker that's why it's
called a speed peeler
looks better now looks a bit naked it
does look a bit naked doesn't it
now you get your spoon
and see
what happens
a teaspoon just takes out all those
seeds
so whilst it sits in the dish
it doesn't make the salad go all soft
because that cucumber is nice and
crunchy
[Music]
that's really good
there you go so see where your knuckles
are there
that's what's always going to protect if
you put that little finger out
this little piggy
boom comes off what did i tell you about
daddy's knuckle that's the first place
you cut off
all the time there you
go the next addition to our prawn salad
is firm juicy baby gem lettuce
look at the lettuce in half what about
the butt
the butts
i'm keeping the butts on for now so when
i slice it it stays together
okay
and then
a little bit there
we don't use
okay
when you prepare lettuce for picnic you
never slice it too thinly
okay otherwise it will it's good prawns
are ready
[Music]
your tummy sauce is ready your dressing
is ready take the lid off
and the trick is
you dress
the bottom of your dish because i'm
going to put the prawns on here to
protect the lettuce
get your cucumber
i put my cucumber on
and then finally that is
okay
now the salad is not gonna go soft why
is that because it's not that it's not
straight onto the dressing that's right
what happens is we wrap this now and
then we get to our picnic drizzle the
sauce on top we mix it up we've got the
dressing on the bottom and the dressing
on top
of the dressing on top that's right
a little bit of tim film do you know the
cling film trick i don't know the twin
film trick yet no thing fell over the
top of the toilet
what you don't understand it when you're
my age
oh you've been my age then well okay
salad in the fridge with the dressing
ready to go for a picnic
this is my ultimate picnic dinner feast
prawn and cucumber salad with a spicy
yogurt dressing
anchovy dip with
crudites and the kids favorite chocolate
marshmallow and peanut fridge cake
you can eat these wonderful picnic
dishes in any combination at any time of
the day breakfast lunch or dinner
donna
polly tilly
ready guys i'm ready
and if you're going on a picnic with a
crowd ladies ready for picnic yeah
do the whole lot as an alfresco feast
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the app store good luck
[Music]
you